[Music]
google just implemented changes that
will make it more difficult to find porn
on the internet
yeah
the announcement was made by google's
new ceo my wife
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's my favorite impression me being
kind
but when you do it you should just go
you should say
congrats on the new job honey
well she's the ceo of google that's
pretty good pretty good yeah
three it
again yeah
everyone watch the uh anyone see that
hurricane sandy concert last night that
was pretty cool they had a lot of great
performers
everybody
every performer that's ever lived was on
that show last night during last night's
12 12 12 concert for victims of
hurricane sandy kanye west performed
while wearing a leather skirt
yeah so now they're having a benefit
concert for people who had to see that
it's a never-ending chain
in a new interview that just came out
new jersey governor chris christie says
he has hired a personal trainer
yeah they're starting slow the trainer
makes chrissy do only five laps around
the cinnabon before going in
that's true
true
pope benedict in the news i couldn't
believe pope benedict has come out with
a children's book
yeah the book is called stay the hell
away from father o'malley
[Applause]
i'm getting a call yeah
my mom's gonna call uh
i didn't like it
and father o'malley is very mad yeah
there's no real father o'malley
that was for legal uh hey today's taylor
swift's 23rd birthday
taylor said she just wants to spend a
quiet evening at home breaking up with
someone
hey get this sarah palin's son track
has filed for divorce from his wife
yeah
i say good luck finding another woman
willing to say i love you track
they don't grow on trees
oh track
you're the one for me
i can't get enough of
track scientists now believe that
homosexuality is passed down directly
from father to daughter and mother to
son
that crazy yeah
so it's time to face the facts your dad
is a
lesbian
destroyer
it's true my dad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone's like it's true yeah yeah
it's true great thing to bring up when
you go home for the holidays
dad you're a lesbian
sesame street
is going to be tackling the topic of
divorce
on one of their shows can you believe
that
yeah you can tell it's a tense episode
because cookie monster now sings c is
for cheating [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]